conocido por su estilo tranquilo y
fresco charlie watts por decisión propia
nunca cumplió con el estereotipo de rock
star y sin embargo durante más de 50
años fue el corazón de una de las bandas
de rock and roll más icónicas de la
historia los rolling stones este martes
tras conocerse la noticia una oleada de
mensajes han inundado las redes sociales
para despedir a whats muchos de ellos
compañeros de escenario y seguidores del
célebre baterista estoy muy triste de
escuchar que murió charlie watts el
baterista de los stones
le envió todo el amor a su familia
esposa e hija y también mis condolencias
a los stones
[Música]
un día muy triste charly what's era el
mejor baterista el más elegante de los
hombres y una compañía brillante mi más
sentido pésame a shirley serafín de
charlotte y por supuesto a los rolling
stones dios bendice a charlie watts te
vamos a extrañar hombre de paz y amor a
la familia ringo este es charlie what's
llorado y querido por todos what's nació
en londres en 1941 de niño se sintió
atraído por la música jazz comenzando a
explorar su amor por el ritmo incluso
convirtiendo un viejo banjo en un tambor
sin formación profesional el joven
charlie watch aprendió observando a los
bateristas en los clubs de jazz de la
capital británica después de tocar en
varias bandas de jazz and blues pronto
conoció a mick jagger y keith richards y
se unió a los rolling stones en 1963
pero en ese momento whats pensó que no
duraría más de una semana por el
contrario en
1965 fueron impulsados al estrellato
internacional por su estilo incendiario
de música rock and roll llegaron a tener
ocho éxitos número uno en eeuu vendieron
más de 240.000 millones de álbumes en
todo el mundo y realizaron incontables
giras mundiales tocando para sus
legiones de fans a diferencia de sus
compañeros de banda what's generalmente
se resistió a los excesos de fama y se
alejó del centro de atención encontrando
refugio en su matrimonio concilian
shepard a quien conoció en 1964
[Música]